Kuwait's constitutional court has
declared a parliamentary election last
September null and void the court has
ruled that the previous Parliament
should be reinstated last year Kuwait's
Crown Prince dissolved Parliament and
called early elections in a bid to end
political feuding let's bring in badar
al-safe he's an assistant professor of
history at Kuwait University joins us
now from Kuwait City via Skype good to
have you with us on the program sir I
mean how unprecedented is it to have
elections annulled and a previous
Parliament reinstated
Kuwaiti politics defies the obvious uh
this isn't actually a precedent we've
had one happen before so we've had a
parliament annult in 2012 which was also
voted in 2012 it took a bit shorter than
this one this current one stayed for six
months only while the previous uh case
that I referred to has lived on for four
months we've seen a growing assertion of
the Kuwaiti constitutional court and the
Constitutional Affairs of the country
which only makes sense because the court
was built and put in place to look at
ambiguous issues that arise when the
Constitution is not observed and this
has happened yet again it feels like
deja vu 2012 in reality so with the
Constitutional Court having interceded
are we looking at a constitutional
crisis or are we just looking at a sort
of holding pattern until elections
happen again
well the Constitution is quite clear
when
um a parliament is an old dissolved you
have 60 days until the new elections
come through and this is not the case
because you have a parliament in place
right now so you already have the 2020
parliament in place but what I see
happening is the same reasons that led
to the dissolution of the 2020
Parliament the unconstitutional
dissolution now we know from today's
ruling will probably lead us to yet
another dissolution but it behooves the
government at this stage because what
the court points the fingers to is some
government malpractice they should have
done their homework better they should
have researched a much safer way to
dissolve the Parliament and hence the
grounds will be placed now so that they
can prepare for that that moment so now
we will see the 2020 Parliament we
convene the parliamentarians for example
that were never elected to Parliament
before will not be considered MPS if
they were only elected in the 22
Parliament and I foresee a new
Parliament coming through and new
elections in the coming months what do
you think the Kuwaiti public may call
make of all of this I mean you say
Obviously there is President's 2012 is
what 11 years ago the public changes the
Democratic the demographics change the
politics change how do you think the
Kuwaiti public are going to react to
this and and will it change the makeup
of any future parliamentary body that we
see in Kuwait City
let me tell you kuwaitis are exhausted
uh we we feel that this has
been taking much of this team that is
required and the energy that is required
to develop the country uh there is much
ridicule mode out there today concerning
the recyclicality of the system there
needs to be a major reset and that major
reset as I've called in many of my
pieces in the past requires new thinking
we need to think of a new political pact
we need to think of a new constitution
we need to think of new rules of
engagement so trying to continue in the
same fold hasn't been helpful it hasn't
helped Kuwait in the near past and it
will not help it in the near future
which say what happens brother I'll say
thanks for joining us from Kuwait City
thank you
thanks